have to go and rinse my name's perfect
today we're gonna do another oculus rift
game this one is called don't let go
basically I'm supposed to hold on to my
keyboard no matter what happens so we'll
see how that goes
okay I'm ready brother huh Chuck hi
okay playing my game okay if you're not
playing with headphones right now please
go get him it's not much better if you
have headphones you start the game yes
press both control keys on your keyboard
how am I supposed to find them don't let
go but how am I supposed to find them
okay there's one here we go rice huh
what's happening noddies yeah [ __ ] game
base I'll headbutt you if I have to [ __ ]
I hate bugs
[Music]
it's going inside my what oh hello there
mister after how are you today
that's fantastic great to see you Tara
wait why tractor where after we have a 5
feet distance rule come on Raptor Raptor
I'm not gonna make out with you I told
you make out with you not cool Raptors
you just have to get over it
get another girlfriend I mean boyfriend
whatever ow
what was that [ __ ] Raptors or crazy
this is awesome so far what's gonna
happen holy [ __ ] huh huh well maybe this
isn't scary enough for you oh no no no
no you know there's a giant spider
behind this level oh come on really
wants to meet you
no no no no no I don't like spiders
what wanting spiders what we're right I
hate spiders come on
what no oh okay good I was hoping he
would do that why is it getting darker
no no no no no I don't like this oh
[Music]
bloody what
Oh oh no god damn it never came a demon
sacrifice again oh wow it happen it's
not the first time why'd it okay that's
cool you guys I'm glad you guys are
having fun cuz I'm shy come on what
don't [ __ ] with my brain please
what's that what okay okay that okay I
give up congratulations ah yes you win
no I'm still on let it go actually let
me try it one more thing okay bring it
on [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's so cool that's so cool I think
this games like this that are made for
the oculus are like the coolest thing
ever because there's some really smart
and funny ideas that you can make and I
think this is just one of them so I hope
it was enjoyed watching at least
watching me get the camera freaked out I
guess that's the point of this channel
at this point they don't like if you
know you're watching a house man like
let me know if you want more octo this
there's a ton of them out there it's the
sky from Earth today I'll see in the
next 1000 book
[Music]
[Applause]